[Music]
wake up early in the morning press play
and let's get it in cause we rocking
with the fighter
[Music]
happy monday kids super bowl weekend
that's right super all weekend before we
get in this juicy ass super bowl
i was at korean barbecue with half the
squad in here
you guys didn't go you also didn't come
to my super bowl party so
double [ __ ] you know we went over this
it was only six allowed
yeah true you couldn't but you still
could have came so take that [ __ ] you
back
no no no you could have killed you would
have came anyway i would have came
if it was a group activity on the game
everyone oh there's a group activity at
my house
me and malik and our two white girls
yeah we would have came we're talking
about this we've never
no one's ever met your girl in here and
they haven't
oh he has yeah she's the only one we're
just making sure she's real
yeah i love that that's real because jim
for a while had the same issue
[Laughter]
i'm not gonna lie when i watched y'all
instagram stories you're jealous
i was a little jealous and you should be
but don't be jealous at this
okay over a two hour wait to eat this
[ __ ] korean barbecue it was a two
hour wait
a half are you two and a half two half
hour away for two and a half hours
peep it did y'all watch we 7 30 was the
time we're supposed to get there
me and chin get there at 7 30 right cat
was getting tattooed so she came later
stevie got there right around 7 30.
and chingos check in and he's like i can
see auntie's face he's all
they said it's like a two hour wait uh
and in my head i just want to be up
front with you and i was like well i'm
out of it
dude if someone was like hey michael
jackson's gonna be performing up the
street he came out of the grave he's
gonna do all his greatest hits but you
gotta wait
two hours i would not wait yeah i
wouldn't wait let alone
wait for [ __ ] korean barbecue yeah
i'm already suspect as it gets with
korean bbq
two hours two hours dude so we wait two
hours because the only thing that saved
me is there's boba across the street
i'm on a boba kick right now i can't get
enough i said i know what i'm gonna do
wait for everybody so i get uh we fill
up on boa we have nice chats
chin uh gets everyone liquored up we
filled up on whiskey
okay i was drinking buffalo trace all
night chin persisted
that we drink non-stop which we did it
with time to back up
so finally we sit down and uh it was it
was [ __ ] good
food huh didn't it was very good have
you been there before cat yeah i've been
there a bunch of times
really yeah oh damn she's been when it's
legit like when you're actually inside
the restaurant yeah this was a little
different
you can't i assume was that i had to
make sure you kept going dude it's way
better when we're inside i went yeah he
said that
five minutes later dude if we were
inside i was like dude if you don't shut
up
i'm trying to enjoy whatever [ __ ] meat
i'm eating right now
yeah it was it was good it went to
quarters barbecue cranberry he was
[ __ ] fire
here's the thing it's the first time in
la that i felt
completely normal koreatown was
possible say it again say it again
dude again they didn't give a [ __ ]
it was the first weekend everything was
open dude i'm talking
traffic parking impossible to find yeah
restaurants
dude we almost there
we crawl through some [ __ ] like andy the
frame we almost there
i like that we want them here
dude and i experienced my first little
racism oh you did yes
yeah i actually enjoyed it i went to the
bathroom
i walked by this korean table and the
they don't have their mask on and i see
the guy staring at me i was like i went
like this
i thought maybe he noticed me or
something and i go like this and he's
like
at least spring is why there's so many
[ __ ] white people
it was weird and i was like wait did
they see steve and cat go to the
bathroom this would be fun oh just a
real white guy because i'm kind of you
know like is he
yeah stevie white as [ __ ] white blue
with a hot asian girl they must have
been like
[ __ ] that white that's what chin used to
be like
chin hated seeing white guys with asian
girls i didn't use me like that
i didn't hate it but it was yeah you
hate it i will say this
we gave them names too what would you
call victimization
when they're white guys white guys
always grab the asian girls because they
love white dudes
yeah mostly but everyone loves like
because it started with the war right
victimization basically
is it a world war ii thing what are we
talking about it's the one what do you
think
most here's the thing it's like world
war ii i feel like there's a lot of
people who like
things that are different from what they
are so like
asian girls like white guys or black
guys just because that's different from
what you grew up with like
you probably like something other than
white girls because you grew up with
white girls oh your dating was black
girls wasn't it
in the beginning or jake the hot is hot
you know what my type is smoking hot
yeah white
black asian with you filipino
africans what it was rashford
both of us for a long time yeah we love
it but like
asian guys who hate on asian girls for
dating
other races only say that because they
don't have game
there are asian guys who have game who
never hate on asian girls for dating
outside oh that's
that's right that's life that's life in
jail it's like it's like with us
like like black women we mean us
we got white girlfriends like black
women will go hard on us
but like if if uh if a black girl is
with a white dude
they get a lot of praise they don't get
praised
the white guy definitely does it no
let's see he doesn't know
you yeah i don't know i stay on world
star hip-hop
dude the [ __ ] the shade the shade
they clown they clown on white white
dudes that are with black girls they
count on the black girl
the black girl gets [ __ ] i feel like no
no they they climb on the block oh you
couldn't find a black king like look
michael b jordan gets so much hate
because it's the word around town is he
date a lot of white women
right so there's like ah he fine but he
date white women now he's with
my future girl uh laura harvey yeah now
there's like oh that's why i'm talking
about sis and all like get that bag sis
now uh let's see what black girls with a
white guy uh serena williams
serena williams or eve they say like get
that
hold on hold on but get that bag because
they're married to
billionaires both of them are
billionaires yeah but they probably so
it's like get that bad girl
in there yeah
normal white dudes one started [ __ ]
reddit i think
oh the other one yeah one and eve's
guy's like a billionaire too yeah he's a
billionaire
not maybe not billiard but they're
[ __ ] wealthy but he yeah he he read a
guy's super wealthy yeah
but eve was already wealthy before that
yeah but she would a billionaire now not
like him
yeah not like she doesn't have [ __ ] you
barbara sharp didn't blow her up but she
had her own tv show eve
yeah she had it on tv one yeah no i get
that that was a long time ago fellas
residuals residuals i don't think
residuals now
she's still not paid like her man no no
no that's where your bag comes from yeah
i got you she leveled up
did you feel any hate with steve because
stevie you know he's from boston he's a
boston white boy yeah
that's even he's even wider than like
you know what that's white white
white white he's like winter hill game
white say it twice white white
do you get do you get weird looks like
if you like you and stevie are in public
like
you see some more asians and they like
steve and i went to asian tables like
you believe this [ __ ] man
this culture stealing [ __ ]
young and we i didn't grow up yet we're
just kind of like why are they like the
white guys and then when you get older
it is a game it is like how you talking
also why does it matter a good lead like
stephen a good looking dude like good
looking dudes good looking dude
white black yeah you know don't matter
good like i've seen some fire ass
asian dudes that look good yeah africans
or whatever it don't matter bts
good looking is good were those not i
wouldn't say good looking
those are very feminine dudes now you
said it was a few names you called so
victim my asian is one well no just
victimization
it was more there had been like a racial
term though it was more for fun though
yeah kind of because we were like yeah
we couldn't get the girls oh man they
always they always pick the the hot
or good looking white guy so we're just
like joking around not actual hate
though
no do you do you feel weird do you like
you walking around with your girl or
anything like
i walk around like the king i am yeah
you don't care yeah yeah but
if you go around the homies i bet
there's some slang twists
you haven't been around the homes yet go
ahead your girl has never been her
do you take her to like prince charles
you don't take it
no we stay above the 10. stay above the
10. yeah
because you don't want to do what but
and you don't post her online so they
don't know
what she's not online i took uh i took
my girl to the uh
that uh movie theater and chris shaw
michael johnson
no it's a really like game you don't
have to clutch your pearls like that
it was the cheapest one it was the
cheapest theater so we went we went
there but
you you don't feel uncomfortable i don't
either because i'm like
like my family loves her all that stuff
so that that's all that matters to me
anyone else i don't give a [ __ ] you know
but y'all y'all homies yeah
listen love is love now do you get weird
looks with your girls that's what i'm
saying
but i bet you get weird she does it you
do
like if you're at like a ritzy white
part like if you're an orange like
newport or something you go to
say you know some fancy uh let's say you
go to javier's out there
do you get weird looks because she's
with because you're not like
like skin black let's call it what it is
let me say something you ain't not a
light skinned i love like how you try to
tip-toe it up
[Applause]
whenever i see a black guy with a white
girl i'm like yeah i bet he got a big
ass dick
that's as i assume i think they're
packing i think that's what a lot of
like white people think
whenever they see it yeah i sell a brand
like ooh i pay a big old dick
black white girl uh i don't know i never
really noticed because i'm not like i i
don't walk around like
curious if people were like you know
looking at me yeah that was the first
racism i've
ever experienced yeah yeah well you're
welcome
oh i encourage you like yes more more
and more more
happy black history month yeah the food
the food was good that was it yeah it
was good we had to cook our own food
here's the problem
he don't [ __ ] with you boy your boy
channel are weird
[ __ ] weird weird because that we we'd
have it on the grill and chimney i ate
that [ __ ] just like that man but i could
tell he was like
holding back no he's holding back and
he's like i'll eat it and this pork was
not cooked
and chin was like i'll eat raw chicken
the beef you were [ __ ]
the beef was like scared the beef was
like that's racist the beef was
cause i called him a dog is that racist
no not at all i'm kidding oh
he ate dog that's right
as long as it's good meat i eat it the
way i'm not getting
real that dude that night in the morning
i didn't i didn't feel great
i feel good i i i think it was the pork
you made it you forced me i didn't force
anything
but no people do eat raw chicken in
japan yeah
you can't do you can't do this it's just
how the chicken is raised and taken care
of it has to be like
chicken so they eat they ate the chicken
from here in america no no you would
never do that yeah you [ __ ]
even pork you don't want to do so wait
you eating form raised chicken raw
when you're lying oh yeah i had to
change it up
lions don't eat chickens
i feel
that's chicken that's [ __ ] disgusting
no but
it's all it depends on how it's how it's
raised it's where it's from
all that stuff feel so you hate that so
it has to be pretty much
natural natural chicken i mean yeah it's
got to be nothing
crazy uh yeah can i actually can i do it
let's be dude the food was
fantastic though and we would dip it in
the sauce my mouth i could eat it right
now
and then what was like the garlic pork
chin it was like the in the red garlic
sauce or whatever
um i think it's just it's marinated god
marinated beef it was [ __ ]
fire it was fire and there was like
there's a we had like fillet we had we
had
i'm sorry it was really nice though jen
now was i
starving an hour later yeah i was yeah
because it's just like it's basically
no carbs no carbs they tried chin try
tossing a [ __ ]
thing of vegetables like what the [ __ ]
are you doing the edamame out of here
oh that's so good washing tomatoes like
what the [ __ ] are you doing
was it worth the two-hour wait though
i'll
go ahead and say it was a fun night
if it was just me and my girl no but
because we're drinking and like chilling
and it was like our first night out and
it was popping the environment was
it was lit it was cool yeah it was cool
but any other time
no what's it on chin what like what's
it's on eighth
um you know koreatown well sixth street
i live right over there
you live by koreatown yeah real close to
koreatown we should go to uh
sixth street like i'm not too far from
you know like where the wheel turned
theater is
yeah yep not too far from that area
did you get that egg oh i don't think we
did oh we did yeah y'all have the egg i
don't touch egg dude
he doesn't like eating after breakfast
egg
is a it's a breakfast yep meat freeze
breakfast you don't touch
egg outside breakfast wait if it's past
nine a.m there's no egg in my food dog
no
unless you put it on my burger put it in
my [ __ ]
ramen put it in my salad
what about if you haven't in a beef
tartare because that's usually like uh
but no you put it on top no what's a
beef tartar
rustic and i [ __ ] with that but even
that one i mean i don't think i've ever
had
why'd your stomach hurt though uh
because jim made me eat raw pork
hey wait wait wasn't wrong you drive by
uh cecil
hotel oh listen to this yes you drove by
you're going to be able to
sent this email to my brother said yo i
got an idea okay
you guys are on episode 650 for episode
666.
okay you guys should record it from
cecil hotel come on man
and i told you stay left
it has to be at night yeah all right
okay we have to record it at night not
cat let me catch you we'll figure it out
last oh yeah you weren't a haircut
you're getting uh your tattoo yeah
so what's happening so look let's take a
little break from the shenanigans
hashtag free brittany hey fellas we are
in the thick of winter and a storms are
brewing
and there's storms in your pants i'm
talking about that one to three inches
uh that you need to trim all right in
that bush area
in your pants luckily our partners at
manscape
specialize in products to make sure
you're walking around town with
beautiful snowballs talking about your
junk talking about your hairy junk
straight up
manscape is here to provide you with the
best tools for your grooming experience
offering precision engineer tools for
your family jewels all right
the lawnmower 3.0 is the best hygiene
tool
ever ever all right advanced skin safe
technology so you don't snag your nuts
all right
you don't have to worry about cutting
them once you cut them you know how much
they bleed not anymore man
not anymore manscape performance package
is the best buy at 2021.
the performance package comes with a new
improved lawnmower 3.0
my favorite product of theirs the weed
whacker you got the long nose hairs
maybe your grandma has some air hanging
over here
you need the weed whacker nose air hair
trimmer whatever it is
performance boxer briefs and the travel
bag this all comes in the performance
package right
so get on it man you need to use the
best tools to get the job done
and that's why you need manscape they
got a crop preserver anti-shaving ball
deodorant i put between my thighs when i
ride my bike they have the crop reviver
it's a spray on toner for your balls
made with soothing alloy
which helps you get your ball smooth man
and don't get cold feet this winter get
20
off and free shipping by going to
manscape.com fighter
they also have a ton of other amazing
men's hygiene products on their website
turn this one off with free shipping by
going to manscape.com that's 20 off and
free shipping by going to manscape.com
fighter thanks manscape for making our
winter wieners look
good hey man 2021 guess what's popping
these days we're talking about mental
health it's finally a thing we could
finally talk about it
and feel normal because everyone
struggles from time to time and therapy
helps straight up
therapy is the best way to get your mind
right to get happy to deal with the
stress
of everything going on in the world
whether it's covid your family
finances you need to talk to somebody
not your best friend
not your buddy went through the 12-step
program i'm talking about licensed
professionals and that's where
betterhelp
connects you all right that connects you
a licensed therapist
you can do a video phone there's live
chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to or you can can do it on video all
right
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy you can start communicating
with the therapist in under 48 hours we
got you man join the millions of people
who are seeing what therapy is really
about see if it's for you
because you are the greatest asset all
right and this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp
and then find the kids listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
fighter that's betterhelp.com fighter
so what's happening so look have you
heard of ceso hotel
i have not been to the seasonal hotel
yeah like two serial killers live there
yeah millions of people have
jumped off commit suicide from there
definitely haunted millions of people
nope not much just exaggerated but uh
let me see it's a haunted hotel we're
gonna
uh record episode 666 from there yeah we
don't have
we don't have to do this we don't have
to but it'd be great we're gonna do it
come on the bands are in we're in the
fans are in
yeah they're ready so it's gonna be dope
now i'm not staying the night because i
gotta wake up and uh yeah yeah yeah yeah
kids
but what what chin but here's the thing
you guys stay the night yeah we're back
the next day
[ __ ] out of here who wants to stay we're
gonna we
have the room for the whole night jen
already chin already slept there
oh i've already
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
a man that's a great question the kids
pay for it i'll i'm with it alex 666
what is that that's why we're going to
do that it's
it's in a month why can't they figure
out them
666 is just a number leave that [ __ ]
number along let it be
a nice number [ __ ]
bro yeah keep growing your beard so you
can look like richard ramirez
hmm well he didn't have a beard he had
his beautiful hair though
his hair is who is here and [ __ ] up
teeth i [ __ ] up he got him fake he had
veneers when he went
i like how he fixed his teeth in prison
i want to look like a killer as well any
other killers
oh there's one black serial killer okay
the dc sniper
bring up dc sniper let's see whatever he
used to be in the gas station shooting
people
did that kid get done oh no that there's
the guy there there he is
yeah can you look like that in a month
yeah for sure
my hair is kind of like almost ready oh
yeah don't cut your hair grow out the
facial hair
okay we'll get you yeah orange juice
okay well he didn't have an orange
jumpsuit at the time when he was killing
people that the dude on the left is dead
right
i don't know so they both did it
together yeah yes him and his son he
brought him into it or something right
or like
yeah they do it together that was scary
when it was happening because i really
remember
i was out how long ago was that i was
out there that was a 2000 early 2000s
2002 i was not out there i lied we
didn't know who the dc sniper was
no we i was i was thinking he was what
he's from new orleans
there we go i got to represent john
again he died until
nine yeah 2009. uh executed lethal
injection probably for the better
yeah is this is his son alive that's not
his son
i forget who that is it's kind of like
might be his uncle or some [ __ ]
that one that one have all the serial
killers that one
bores me it's not that fun wait
he was shooting people while they were
walking yeah but
so wait the news made it seem like he
was the [ __ ] 10 killed
what does it say about him 17 he's alive
he's alive
35 years old yeah is he on uh death row
i don't know i don't think no he was
younger and they think he got like
pressured into it but he's still in he's
still he's locked up for life
anytime soon damn post sentencing
okay so long story short episode 666 i
can't wait cecil hotel i'll line it up
chin you look at hotels book the suite
right it can't be expensive i mean come
on
now can i be throwing this if you can
ask for the richard ramirez room
specifically it's on the fourth floor
cat can you dress up like a girl on the
elevator no i can't
copy that yeah i know she she was crazy
oh dude hashtag free brittany hashtag
baby brittany
hashtag free you've seen have you seen
the you haven't the britney spears it's
a i'd say documentary
it's a one-part documentary it was
started on fx it's on hulu if you
haven't seen it
it's not really a spoiler because we
kind of know what's going on in her life
so it's in i saw a preview for it i'm
like i need something to watch i'll
record that i gotta quit watching people
dying
i'm gonna watch britney spears career's
dime whatever i record it
dude that [ __ ] was insane
insane insane insane the way the media
treated britney spears
was [ __ ] up [ __ ] i told you guys last
night
they came over the super bowl party
hashtag good friends hashtag back friend
and when you guys came over
that's like free brittany for real free
for real i'll protest with you guys yeah
let's do it when you watch that
how bad do you feel i kept standing up
and getting mad getting mad
yes i kept going what the [ __ ] because
dude her father controls everything
everything if he wasn't in her life she
has no sign even in her he was not part
of
her come up at all she goes crazy
quote-unquote crazy after she loses her
children they won't let her see her
children when she shaved her head into
all that [ __ ]
it was because she couldn't see her kids
she was going [ __ ] nuts
dude you take my kids on top of
paparazzi
yeah oh my god the paparazzi was so
[ __ ] up
is that legal well now they've changed
the rules a little bit but kind of
because they were like all up in her
[ __ ] face but how [ __ ] up was it
how [ __ ] up was it when she was uh
doing interviews they're like uh
have you had sex justin timberlake yeah
they could never do that now
yeah and the way they treat her she was
like a kid when that happened
it was you know she was a kid yeah she
was a teenager you watch that you're
like what the [ __ ] is going on
right it was making me just mad and then
how about they have no how about they
have that one guy on there who uh he did
a bunch of documentaries
uh and it was anderson cooper and
they're like this just in britney spears
goes crazy and then he goes
i got an idea how would you just leave
her alone michael moore goes
how about you just leave her alone why
you guys like just leave her alone why
is everyone bugging and then cnn
scooper is like oh they seize up he's
like i got an idea how would you [ __ ]
leave her alone man yeah
that was my thing like leave her alone
yeah so like they they forced her
to pretty much you know react the way
she reacted think about it like if you
like there was like 12 just 12
characters like in her face in her face
all the time she she went to the gas
station
she was in the gas station to go to the
restroom she was coming out the restroom
they they hounded her at the at the
[ __ ] uh
the door she was walking out of the
restroom and then they have a attorney
on there and they're
asking about you know uh basically contr
power control like she signed over and
her dad
has full power of her career finance
yeah real estate everything
and the attorney was like oh i went to
visit her just to see like mentally
where she's at
she's like she's aware of what her
father
represents the power that he asks and he
goes just ask her a few questions right
away he's like oh no she doesn't need
this
yeah like she he shouldn't have this
control over oh so they even went to
court with it and they still
they still grant her access crazy
so when they go to court she's paying
for her her lawyers
and her and his are you serious and then
the person who was handling all her [ __ ]
goes i need a raise and like whoa this
isn't how it is
yes when it's supposed to be a
conservatorship that takes care of her
because the conservatorship is usually
in put in place because a person can't
take care of themselves
and so obviously she could uh
the uh court says that she mentally was
unable to take care of herself and she
had so much money that she would have
been taken advantage of so they put her
father in place in charge of
her as a person and her finances and
what she's saying is i
i don't want my father do it because
he's a bad guy let a bank do it if
you're worried about that she goes i
think i'm fine but if you
if you're real really worried about that
let a bank do it not my father is
different intentions
yeah yeah it's nuts how much was she
worth
worth a lot she's worth a ton and then
now she goes i'm not going to perform
until you yeah she won't put yes
she won't do anything she has all these
offers like she's like i'm not going to
work until he doesn't have power
yeah because he's getting her money
she's getting when she was like doing
the
american idol stuff because like she was
it was
where she was the residency in vegas
remember that
yeah vegas yeah then how about that one
being her dad put together what she's
going to do like
a ton of shows in vegas and she's
supposed to perform but she's like
help her out man yeah it's it's insane
and then
and then you look and then you hashtag
free brittany hashtag please free
brittany
and then you uh hashtag baby one more
time but then you
hit me with your best shot but uh that's
not hurt
to say wait wait wait wait wait wait
you're you're you're you're you're dude
you watch it and it's
so funny oh dude and then her her social
media she's literally crying for help
she she's literally like she's giving
all these signs like i need help man
even when she was on that horse yeah
everything anything she
when she goes on shows me because her
dad's so [ __ ] old don't know how it
works yeah
that's her asking for help from the
from the outside even
i think federer line is like backing her
up too everyone is yeah her brother
how about how about whatever your
brother he was like all the
strong-minded women
and they got the interviewer was like
well that's a good thing right he's like
just certain extent he sounded bro he
sounded
he sounded [ __ ] whack this is crazy
this is crazy what is that this is our
instagram where's the crowd no i don't
know what that i'm talking about
no this is her just bored as [ __ ] but uh
go back get out of here chin
go to the one where she looks crazy the
media
well that far left one with the video
the
another big black guy being another big
you want to go to the black one yeah let
me see the body let's do it
a lot of you guys have been writing in
and you want to know what my main goals
are for 2021
number one is to meditate more number
two is to take a cooking class
number three is to do a pilates class
and actually follow through with the
class
and number four is i've got to try this
ice cream diet
okay so i heard a lot of you guys see it
signs right there when she walked back
and forth
she's pacing you know and she's reading
off something let's read it exactly we
took that
acting class
i'll say this though after watching some
of this [ __ ] i'll say this
hashtag free bernie or choreography
brittany
but also like there's something off
right it's like
you get a weird vibe when you're
watching this stuff and as much as
when you watch that the documentary
obviously has a narrative
to make us feel this way which we get
and she should have control over [ __ ] if
she's going to spend all our money and
give it to bad people
she's a grown adult she can do that
happens to a ton of celebrities
but we don't know the facts so for a
court to go now the dad still should
control it it make and this is a court
that's supposed to be not you know
unbiased
we don't know exactly what's going on
she might be batshit
crazy we're all free britney but she's
like she's like [ __ ] that free me you're
like whoa
but also at the same time you got to
look at the way she came up
like i mean those early interviews with
her like
the way the public and the media trader
was insane justin broke up you know
people are
harassing justin like you owe her an
apology he's like [ __ ] what
yeah he's like and they said you kind of
like made the she remember
video based off of like yesterday great
song i remember that's a great song she
did she
now you get paid for documentaries who
get paid for that
uh uh no i don't think i don't think she
didn't participate in it there's like
people who make money off of
documentaries but i don't think you can
pay people to be in it no no no no i'm
still saying who
yeah that's a good question i don't know
wait what is wait what is your question
he's saying like did britney spears make
money off that doc i don't think so he's
not associated with it
like like oj don't use like the oj docs
and stuff he doesn't get paid off that
like the richard ramirez docks or
charles manson they don't get paid off
that
but certain ones i think if they're in
it
so they said they reached out for
brittany to be in it and they they never
heard back
and they think that she never they never
never got to her
okay because so so so you and stevie
argued because yes
my girl my girl's like you should do
something about this talk bring light to
another show i'm like
i'm just i hear you
i hear you i'm i'm not oprah you know
and my
however made people see this i get it
what's your girl saying also
hashtag free britney but also it's kind
of like this tiger king like the
like joe exotic we're like we gotta get
him out
yeah yeah kind of but also he
really did hire someone to kill this
other person yeah he kind of should
probably do some time
yeah i know it's a cool thing to do with
brandy too like you see these videos
you're like
hashtag free britney but also also
controller finances you know
i mean but that's yeah i just think it's
tough because it is super because
the media the media paints a certain
page all the time
with everything whether it's online or
media which online is kind of
so is media now yeah they'll paint a
narrative and you can really run with it
a certain way you know
dude when i was listening to like when
when they were interviewing like the
that pop those paparazzi dudes i wanted
to fight themselves
i'm like bro y'all did this to a person
like it's
it was like torture bro the way they had
these cameras up in her face
but it happens a lot so they basically
killed princess diana too
yeah that was good i was going to bring
that up another one for you and i just
listened to this
uh podcast forget the name of it shout
out to whoever did it uh on the brittany
murphy one you remember brittany murphy
yeah
well so that one's interesting too
because the paparazzi kind of [ __ ] on
her
and like paint her in a bad light so she
couldn't get a job and then that
perez hilton was kind of a piece of [ __ ]
he was doing an interview and they said
who do you think's gonna like be the
next like marilyn monroe or something
like that and he goes
i i wouldn't be surprised if britney
murphy dies the next three months
she died in like three months so it's
just like this toxic
such a great actress by the way i love
her she was great i loved her was i
heard
that uh she heard ashley kutcher just
married just man great movie
anyways but so steven was like yeah
there has to be some reason
because when the court of law was like
yeah but the dad still should run some
of it and we'll bring in the bank so now
the bank is involved debate yeah
and the dad still still involved but
when i hear that and you're talking
about high-powered lawyers and they're
really looking into the case
and you have she's getting evaluated
like her mental capacity
there's something going on there man see
i think it's weird that she
is technically unfit mentally to take
care of herself but somehow she's fit
enough to perform constantly and bring
in all that i know and they make that
that's where like it doesn't make sense
to me and all the exactly she's crazy
and all her co-workers are all dude her
like her mentality is insane
oh yeah even the dancers are like she's
a beast yeah they're like
everything she has like a specific eye
for what she wants but she doesn't want
i told my girl i went man you know for
what
you know hopefully not but if someone
took my kids from me like say me my girl
got divorced somehow she had a case
where you take my kids from me dude
i'd be going [ __ ] nuts too man crazy
and that's a mom
a mama bird and those kids no of course
she goes [ __ ] nuts yeah they got
cameras on her face
yeah like when she tried to go to k
fed's house to try to see her kids
and he wouldn't let her let her and
that's when they caught that famous
photo of her
uh
the paparazzi dude was like yeah like
you know like
he was saying like oh we need each other
meaning like was like she needs us as
much we need her like yeah
i know you're back at it you're the best
person get out of a bad [ __ ] person
he tried painting him so he's like you
know i always ask if she's doing all
right like get the [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] out of here you didn't you didn't
give a [ __ ] no pop they don't pop
no one gets scum of
they can't do that anymore there's some
i don't know what what are the rules
with paparazzi now jen you have a
computer in front of you
[Laughter]
let's see across the pond and the
continent in california probably are
legally prohibited from trespassing on
private properties in telephoto lenses
to survey private property
pursuing targets and cars however many
criticize the laws having little in the
way of
teeth to back up its threats of
liability
and you know some celebrities so let's
say so wait let's say you get super
famous and you're out to uh dinner with
your girl
and a paparazzi snaps a picture of
chappelle lacy and then it's a good
picture you look great in it
and then you post it on your instagram
celebrities getting sued
by the paparazzi and winning going well
that's my
that's my work you owe me money well if
he tags him it doesn't matter
it's like dude that's my work it's like
yeah but it's me and i didn't give you
access
i didn't tell you to shoot that photo
are you weird
it's [ __ ] up another one that's weird
is when paparazzi follows around
uh child stars so [ __ ] up it's it's so
weird like how can a grown man or grown
woman follow a child around
la or wherever they are to snap a photo
dude when they showed me like walking
out of a hotel with him like a
four-year-old son
son and you you see him he's like
imagine that kid man
how do those paparazzi not have a
[ __ ] human heart
and just [ __ ]
did you see where they got the paparazzi
dudes were getting in the fight
that was pretty funny or when they take
pictures of celebrities like when
they're on the beach and
who knows man maybe they're taking a
break from the crazy life in strict life
and
they're a little out of shape like go
look at the gut on
insert celebrity name yeah it's like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you guys
or they shoot a bad picture like kim k
like look at her dumpy ass
like all right your dumbass it's so
small that's true they used to make a
million dollars off of one photo of
britney spears that's
insane what they were making they used
to sell a photo of britney they're
hoping that she looks disheveled and
just out of it they could sell a photo
of her for a million dollars back in the
2000s
that's why i saw crazy so the tabloids
ate that [ __ ] picture yeah that's how
they got their money
and then he and then the guy from i
think his people or us weekly
was like our marketing budget was 170
grand a week
and he was like we put a ton of it into
brittany he's like tens of million
dollars went to them following brittany
it's like [ __ ] you man
they so they can't follow people like
that anymore right there's some rule now
if you're at home they can't take
pictures stuff like that but if you're
out and about they still can
it's so disrespectful we see him at the
airport all the time
tmz waiting for him and that that's the
airlines the people on the airlines
the the call up tmz like hey drake
booked a flight
to toronto from l.a so when they land
they know they're there
yeah it's like airport people releasing
like names who book flights that's how
they find out
so they get paid for that they're like
give me a tip there's like this weird
thing that uh
because uh adam sandler had stayed at
the hotel that i worked at
him and him and like his whole squad and
um
there was like a line of just people out
there i'm like how the [ __ ] did they
know that the hotels
there's a yeah there's this thing that
basically this like kind of forum or
website or something
that could basically you could basically
follow where uh like a person like
that's on tour
yeah a celebrity that's like on tour or
something and find out like all these
things
about them it's kind of funny you book
airbnb son you can't [ __ ] traffic
it's crazy yeah it's super crazy i feel
bad like because yeah we would get like
in the hotel i worked that we would get
like all the the basketball teams and
like football teams and [ __ ]
and so people knew when they were coming
in and knew like
everything they knew everything i'm like
how the [ __ ] it's gonna be like
line and i i can't imagine like what
britney deals with like that's insane
oh dude and the kids and like you'd go
nuts
you'd go [ __ ] nuts you're the kids i
remember brock lesnar
was uh telling a story where he had his
kid in his armless one brock was like
the biggest thing in the world and was
fighting the ufc he was getting ready to
fight i think cain velazquez was shane
carl in
one of his big fights and he walked out
of like a gas station restaurant and had
his daughter in his hands
and the paparazzi was so frantic they
grabbed him while his daughter was his
hands and he almost dropped his daughter
dude he was like oh i will rip your face
off
if you touch me again i will rip your
[ __ ] faces off and they're like okay
we have that we have that video i would
love to think kind of what did kanye
didn't kanye
[ __ ] up one of their cameras yeah yeah
he like tossed the camera but you can
see why they do man
like it's insane it's not
damn hashtag free britney hashtag
britney but also
let's get her help yeah yeah and get her
get a better help
i just it's just what it is it'll make
you upset yeah it's like do that why
would you treat a person like that
yeah it makes you so she's so talented
and like you know
we're missing out on brittany because
she's just getting older she could be
touring
she could do residency in vegas but
because you're doing this thing where
her dad has all the power
you're not going to see her perform when
the last time she performed it's been a
minute
two thousand and what i don't give her
someone she performed at an award show
recently
well not recently but the problem she um
but she got a resurgence too man
what was sad was those interviews with
of her as a teen three years ago or two
and a half years
they would like ask her about her tits
yeah they're asking about like oh yeah
everyone's talking about you
and your underwear and your breasts and
she's like i'm just here to talk about
my music
like what yeah she had a titties out no
they just they were just like no
she just dressed normal she was just and
then and then these would be these be
like live interviews and then like big
name like
anchors and analysts would be like oh
well
you know i don't like britney or like i
forget who was not diana sawyer one of
them was like oh
um i hate what she represents for women
i would shoot her if i could
but the governor of maryland yeah oh yes
the governor
[ __ ] she's like the weirdest [ __ ]
yeah she was you britney shoot
yeah like that's and they told brandon
that she's like that's terrible
a woman or a man said woman woman and
like she bro a lot of these interviews
like
well at least the interviews they were
showing on the dock like you would just
see her break down and be so
sad what's the end goal for that like i
don't know just you want to see
what everyone likes to watch a star just
fall yeah because they're
not hate their sales yeah because
they've never done [ __ ] with their lives
they like to see that oh
yeah it's [ __ ] terrible man what the
what the mayor of maryland look like
anyway the governor now she said
[ __ ] she looks like [ __ ] [ __ ]
really if i had an opportunity to shoot
britney spears i think i would
damn um and then spears record label
jive respond
it's unfortunate so did she uh
come out and defend that comment no it's
just a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] that lady
i wonder why they i wonder why they
never get like uh
yeah you you see like and then you know
they never really got beyonce like this
you know they never like
she from h you know and she and she i
mean she was a teen too
yeah but she was i think she was in a
group though it's different when she was
a teen she was in destiny's child
and then as she she like mid-20s then
she became like they're saying too when
britney was coming up like
they just talked about her sexuality all
the time yeah she's and then that's all
it was during bowie bands so then no one
talks like no one talked about justin
timberlake or nothing like that ever
no one really talked about any of those
guys they just [ __ ] on britney all the
time
yeah it was literally just so you watch
it like what the [ __ ] is wrong with
people man because now that i think
about it i'll go why her
yeah it was like she wasn't the only one
like christina aguilera was jessica
jessica simpson hitter's honor was
fergie on there who
i read something about britney spears
when she was coming up uh her record
label thought that when she was younger
and she was singing
she's saying so much like christina
aguilera that they didn't want
to compete with christina so they made
her change the way she sung to that i
heard that same thing too
yeah and it damaged her vocal cords in
the long run
and so like it's not even just a
conservatorship that [ __ ] her over
it's like a record label all these other
great oh man
that poor yeah so mismanaged and still
blew the [ __ ] up
yeah so mismanaged [ __ ] being that
famous she better
never i would never want to be that
famous no me neither she better never
those girls you can put them in a line
britney better singer
no better than pink it's better than
fergie no she can't well she's being
better in the [ __ ] show are you
talking about singers you're not better
singer than pink or
christina yeah for sure as [ __ ] pink is
a great singer
pink kid sing things sing sing
christina's probably the best out of all
of them christina's amazing yeah
she does a little she does the most she
does the most she does the most
she's also the thickest she's oh she is
she is okay
hold on now because i'm not even trying
to body stream i'm just saying
she's thick now let's see her today it's
not thick
bro thicker now go to her profile you
know she used to well look at this
she's already super super thin hell no
dude typically
she looked like ariana grande when she
was coming up
the thick come on oh come on malik
and i'm all for it that's fine yeah i
liked it
god damn okay that's her fake fake
pokemon she's justin thicke
go to her ig her eyes she's just she's
just an approved thing
just the
here we go let's see the latest picture
let's see what are we doing we're
talking about her sexuality now
she looks good and also this is it's
promoted on a woman
it's promoted now sexuality she's super
she's sexier now i think than when she's
real skinny
she can sing she can sing
jessica simpson too man is that her
husband
i guess i hope not
what you call a photo dump
and she said she's doing her thing she
good okay shout out to christina
yeah it's wild yeah you never seen him
like attack her like that
you didn't see him attack britney got i
wonder i wonder it just i wonder if it
was like literally britney circle
that like pretty much pushed all that
what like meaning like her circle like
like she probably just had a bunch of
bad people around her is what i'm saying
like the record label and all that yeah
i think every i think everybody was just
like
not in her best interest it was so funny
you feel so it's like
like yeah you like no matter what if
she's crazy and i just feel bad
she didn't have anyone like she grew up
with from the sandbox around her to tell
her like yeah don't say sandbox
uh her her her mom was with her don't
say sandbox
her mom was with her for a little bit
yeah and mom was with the foreign kind
of thing
because she has a younger sister who was
a nickelodeon star by the time brittany
was like an adult
so then the focus goes to the younger
sister the younger sister got pregnant
when she was 16. i'm sure the mom was
taking care of that
oh yeah so it's like i said that's not
talking about jamie right the dad's on
the picture at all during this entire
thing
he wanted a picture at all just yeah
just a little uh
[ __ ] hashtag free britney how's that for
you let's move on
i'm not gonna lie to you man i used
proactive when i was in high school my
face looked like a pepperoni and
proactive was the only thing that helped
me man
and thank god proactive get you clear
skin
all right and you can get this clear
skin by visiting their website
and becoming a proactive subscriber get
the clear skin
feeling productive acne treatment system
have clinically proven
ingredients to clear skin and their
dermatologist tested to be gentle
there's a proactive for you
dermatologist tested proactive has three
different
acne fighting system designed for your
skin type proactiv combines gentle
skin care paired with clinical proven
acne fight ingredients we got you
covered man
if you got bad skin you got acne get on
proactive
right now you've probably heard of it
but you might be too scared to try it
maybe you don't think it works i'm
telling you from
experience it freaking works man it
really really works
all right and right now is a great time
to try proactive for
you firing the kids listeners you can
get a special limited offer by going to
proactive.com
fighter that's p-r-o-a-c-t-i-v
dot com slash fighter subscribe today
and you will receive a proactive
hydrating duo as a free gift
that includes four hydro gel masks and
the green tea moisturizer
best of all you get free shipping again
visit proactive.com
fighter to take advantage of this
special offer right now that's
proactive.com
fighter and subscribe to consistently
get clear skin
man some of you boys are wild out there
some you aren't some you got family it's
time to start thinking nobody wants to
talk about
talking about life insurance your boy
just got it i'm finally growing up
because if something for god forbid will
happen to me i don't want my family on
the streets i don't want them suffering
financially i want them covered and
that's where ladder comes in
we're talking about life insurance
ladder makes it impressively fast and
easy
to get covered you just need a few
minutes and a phone or laptop to apply
ladder smart algorithms work in real
time
so you'll find out instantly if you're
approved no hidden fees cancel anytime
you want
since life insurance costs more as you
age now is the time to cross it off your
list your boy just did
i'm 37 son and i got life insurance you
need life insurance super important
put your big ability pants on and get
life insurance so check out ladder today
see if you're instantly approved go to
ladderlife.com fighter
that's l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
fighter uh ladderlife.com watch the
super bowl malik
oh chin let me send you uh malik's tweet
oh gosh this is a funny tweet it's
coming it's it's
gonna be a long week are you saying
sarcastically no no no i'm not saying
okay uh not only was i disappointed
in the game i was disappointed it was
pretty funny with the
xbox we find it we'll talk about it hold
on jason
i have it jason to me goes hey check out
the worst tweet of the year
but he just sent it to me i'm like i'll
send him to the group
he dm me he was like
it was a great tweet it's a terrible
tweet and then also at the time you
tweeted it was is where i'm confused it
was right the super bowl started at 3 30
at
409 malik tweets out today we're about
to witness the goat ball out and tom
brady should be honored to share the
field with him
then tom brady beats he doesn't even
[ __ ] competitive game
13 likes thirteen
than that no it's not there's no way
that's not a lot of
why did you post that well well because
yeah what do you feel you need to do
that it's also a shitty take
no no no it wasn't it wasn't
what happened again tom brady proved to
me that he's the goat i give you that
but um that's i'm not going to be i
don't know why you put the pressure on
patrick mahomes to be the go right now
it's like he's so young yeah let him
just do his
thing yeah yeah this is the [ __ ]
britney spears
yeah this is what you did you
like i'm doing my own i'm over here dude
i'm trying to do my own yeah
everyone wants to compare me like i'm
trying to do my own thing yeah
they asked him a question in super bowl
week how do you feel that people
are giving you the title or you know the
aaron parent to the next goat how do you
feel about that he was like man listen
i'm grateful i'm thankful
but i'm here to just win the champion he
didn't he didn't shy away from it so
he's like they basically
asked him how do you feel about malik b
calling you the goat well i'm just here
to win
i'm trying to make him happy that's
that's what i heard yeah right yeah
you're crazy that was wrong
what are you talking about he did not
shy away from the goat no he kind of
he was like he was like that's up to you
guys like the goats don't have to tell
you how great
yeah yeah any guy fighter basketball
player senior leader the best
they are not the best yeah they're not
well no that's not true like jordan's no
you never have to ask jordan oh floyd
says it all the time he calls himself
the best ever
can we can we can we argue that yeah but
is he maybe five more that do it who but
no we go
with a generation now that the guy
changed that kind of like
situation on the goat if lebron comes
out and says tomorrow
i'm the goat people are like oh but
that's the generation that we live in
today
so that like again i don't have any
problems the greatness you don't tell me
how great you are
the great i can see that we can see yeah
i got it just
just win like tom brady's never called
himself the goat
never he's from that he's so long
michael jordan he's from that michael
jordan era
that you know i'm gonna let my game
speak for myself so is patrick my home
yeah everybody yeah
like patrick my home's now like oh i'm
trying to be a goat like he's just like
he's just playing he's not gonna say
that but he also retweets his
uh you i watch i follow him on twitter
he retweets his stats i mean like the
guy
he doesn't shy away from the
conversation come on man if you're to go
i wouldn't say anything i wouldn't say
anything at all but you're entertaining
now
no no you're entertaining that
conversation i'm gonna assume like yeah
i'm the [ __ ]
and honestly his career the first what
three years has been the best ever
from a young people so therefore he's
got a lot of work to do though he has a
lot of work to do a lot of work to do so
why are you calling him go now he balled
out can't call him
now he bought that i think it's hard to
say he balled out this is the worst game
he's had in life i mean but his
receivers didn't help him at
all he was old but he was but his own
line
but this is what people don't realize
he's missing both tackles yeah his
starting left i could move to guard
so he's missing both tackles he had no
time to throw he was also
injured clearly he had a leg problem and
he's and then his receivers
i would say he's throwing on the money
oh when he hit is hitting receivers
right in their helmet there was
there was two that they should have
caught four uh travis kelsey
the one in the end zone and when he
threw it when he threw on a run on that
other end zone hit him right over the
defender's face
that's three and then right before we i
just watched uh i'll send it to you
twitter no you don't know
yeah but that's four we saw you talk
about the official it was even a game
it was such a boring game it was a boy
from the jump it was like okay
i fell asleep i know you did we saw that
yeah yeah i hate
it it just wasn't a fun game it was like
tampa controlled the whole time petrol
homes doesn't have a full healthy line
so you never believe they're gonna make
a comeback i know brady shut me up like
always so
you never bet against tom brady or floyd
mayweather and i made the mistake so
therefore you know i'm eating my words
today
now speaking of the boring game i want
to get to this i went to xbox
i mean i went to a super bowl party
right now not yours because i don't know
what happened with my invite
all right uh it was clearly there
chappelle tweets or texts yeah c3 stevie
goes yep we'll be there
what was this in the morning you and
justin replied yeah it's probably 10 a.m
yeah oh no
i'll probably sleep look it was it was
like the start of the day yeah i didn't
i didn't see it right after my height
right after my height i apologize so you
know i'd have been i was there
spirit anyway somebody what i was there
i know right what the [ __ ] you just said
harry spears yeah every spirit
damn spirit look
look i went to a super bowl party in
hidden hills all right
i'm talking about everything oh so
you're out by me oh yeah
yeah okay so i mean i'm in a super bowl
party it's not better than brenda's
right
so i'm near my friend duran by the way
he's on the new transformers i told him
that you'll
he don't make a million dollars episode
he was like bro that's that's not true
right so look he's lying we go okay cool
so we get in there and you know you
bring a plus one you were like hey bro
who is this he was like
he's malik b he has a commercial he's
telling me about his premiere and in the
super bowl
right so it's a boring game already no
one's not paying attention
so there's like hey bro all right cool
they shipped it exciting
like hey bro this dude you know what i
mean everybody call me hey xbox you
wanna drink i turn like nah i'm chilling
and all that there's all right get to
the weekend performance
did they tell you that your commercial
yeah
yeah i know that's what i'm saying got
me looking like a liar so then
xbox the you know weekend killed it
there's like hey xbox it's in the game
is it gonna be
like soon because we all chilling we got
like about that stripper party and all
that
i was like yeah it should be soon so i'm
texting you know
my agent i'm like yo any any day now
right she was like yeah they didn't get
back with me
and all that in a couple of weeks ago so
now i'm just sitting there
right so then it's like third quarter we
go there's like yo
malik what's going on my man tell me
like yo they you still gonna premiere
the xbox commercial i was like bro i'll
leak this [ __ ] right now
they was like no i don't do that exactly
i'm on the contract so
fourth quarter they was like hey bro
didn't you say you had an xbox
commercial
i was like yeah so where is it i was
like well [ __ ] i mean
premiere there's alright he lying let's
go ahead and get this super bowl party
started yeah
and they turned the tv off and they
started vibing and you know when girls i
really wanted attention anyway but it
was all on it it was all on me
and what kind of super party's waiting
for this commercial he sounds like uh
chris tucker when he's in jail trying to
explain
how he got caught by the cops that's
what you said
stop playing
yeah well hey it's a long week man it
should happen sometimes
it's not the end of the world i mean
it's funny because someone tweeted me
they was like how did brendan show up
before the super bowl before you i was
like what do you mean
and then they showed me the picture of
the guy running on the field they said
oh yeah everybody yeah everybody here
you didn't see it
it's a picture of some dude like just a
streak in the field but
dude streaks the field but i saw i saw
on the big ones though he like did it
for
uh uh porn thing right
oh he's a porn star no he's he's the
bikini he's wearing is like for a porn
site
usually they get lit up now look at this
move though
[Applause]
he made it to enzo boom
touchdown
[Applause]
it was all clapping he was down at the
one because he slid he slid he down okay
he's down yeah he's down white mike
didn't tell us about that
oh yeah white mike went right yeah he
was lit he had fun yeah he had a blast
dude
he was lit like at what point do we stop
betting against tom brady i know i
didn't bet against him you and i are
supposed to better
yeah you didn't you didn't you didn't do
any best for this game did you no i
switched back malik
i've been 500 with this guy chris lost
how much you bet 500 i didn't know it
was just kind of a boring game i'm
curious what the
what the viewership was like but yeah it
just wasn't
great
what does it say how smart is that
though for this site to do that
like [ __ ] paying whatever gillian
dollars for super bowl commercial let's
have your fat ass straight
out and get attention so uh they
probably paid his bail yeah
yeah i was going to say what happened
we'll be fine yeah we'll be fine pays
bail what is probably
what is the site though i have no clue
vitality
uncensored what is it
either way salute vitali uncensored
he's done that before with that i think
his girlfriend remember her girlfriend
had like really
big tits she streaks somewhere oh it's a
tight move
yeah oh they're back with her tits out
yeah no well yeah
i think she's just thinking about
anything about the marking they're
getting yeah like we wouldn't be talking
about it yeah did i what was he what was
he promoting they're probably
gonna get him in a thong right there
running away chin you see it
[Laughter]
look at this he's in the rock sneakers
oh yeah he is
pulling his pants up that's hilarious
did you enjoy the super bowl commercials
besides
uh i didn't see many of them [ __ ]
spelling with these shoes so i missed
the whole fourth quarter because i had
to
cut them up uh i saw the cardi b
and uh wayne's world one uh solid
they drank one yeah saw the drink one
was funny they were pretty good yeah
they're pretty good oh fantastic
no damn look at that one in a minute
look at that jesus christ
wait wait wait wait wait wait scroll up
where's this right there you see amber
rose
huh different amber rose than i know
now are they having sex or fake blow job
orgy prank
that's not the thing i'm not into pranks
fake blow job or
it's season five episode six it's so
it's like it's whoa
oh this is their body okay you gotta get
got a little weird a little bit
that is insane russian hitman dead body
cleanup prank
uh uh listen i'm not watching porn for
pranks
yeah why are these all pranks piece of
delivery blow job prank
okay well they get they got their
advertising all right
i thought the weekend crushed it i loved
it it was my favorite
uh halftime uh performance i can
remember what beyonce bruno mars
and uh stops singing
i'm out
we can crush it only one i know that
really sang the whole time
yeah and he put his own money into the
production you know you don't get paid
for the super wall yeah i know
he put seven million of his own money up
to make sure it looked exactly how he
wants i think he crushed it man
i thought it was so good my favorite
mine was my other one the other ones are
stupid i can't wait for them to be done
you should carry jlo lip singing shaking
their asses they're 50.
they both killed that one and it was it
was beyonce bruno mars and someone else
what was that band
uh red hot chili peppers nah i wasn't
them uh
that year when beyonce bruno mars and
someone else performed was it that
adam levine yeah was it adam moving oh
maroon 5. yeah
yeah yeah i was like sorry i thought the
weekends was the best as far as like
performances
his was [ __ ] really when they really
sing i'm into it when it's lip singing i
don't give a [ __ ]
yeah tampa looked lit yeah i was like
you're passionate
after parties white mike kept uh texting
me man
florida don't give a [ __ ] florida won't
give a [ __ ] that's what he kept texting
me the whole [ __ ] time
damn they don't no they don't hopefully
they care that same energy when i'm
there in two weeks
tampa yeah temple florida yeah totally
there's that same energy yeah i know
damn dog it was man i i did some shows
over the weekend
out here in l.a man it felt good
it felt really good outdoor again are
they yeah outdoor you know granted
they're outdoor but like the energy is
like
it's back it's still there dawg for it
that's what i'm saying man it was like
it was like like i don't know because i
don't do many local shows
obviously because what's going on but
like man it was just
nice i'm telling you it's just the
energy's still here we're coming back
the energy is still even i think so even
garcetti's dumb ass
but uh for the super he's like don't get
too crazy
we're almost in the end zone meaning
like we're close yeah
oh yeah cleveland he's a complete
[ __ ]
i know when he says we're close you're
like oh wow we're really close yeah
because he's a [ __ ]
yeah he hit punk he's dumb ass oh but
yeah it's
it man it felt good it felt real good
man i'm still stuck on this britney
documentary i'm gonna go watch that
tonight i'm gonna report back again with
my thoughts well no it's over though
yeah yeah because yeah we just yeah we
covered a lot everything
yeah yeah yeah you and i can't give
something yeah well i guess the part we
forgot to make there's a [ __ ] britney
spears podcast of
of two chicks that just talked about her
instagram yeah yeah be a tough podcast
just breaking down her recent instagram
post um
how about those pro how about those
protesters oh bro they davis
yeah wait what they are now they're
brittany they had a google doc
because uh the case was open to the
public and someone
one of them was able to get in and so
the one that was able to get in and
created a google doc
type everything yeah she would type
everything going on everyone yeah
everyone knows oh they are dying
oh yeah super brittany fans what else
could be interesting is that cecil hotel
documentary drops on netflix before
we're gonna air
episode 666 so peter put people on game
what we're doing
oh i can't wait man yes we dope
i can't wait i'm gonna grow my hair out
okay huh oh no dc sniper yeah i got you
guys call me nb
yeah it's gonna be sick no
what you're not bro get on board with
this okay this is gonna be fun
first of all you ain't gonna bully me to
get on board with anything
that's where the show's airing dude yeah
i wasn't gonna miss that episode let us
know
oh y'all bullies like that it's like
that
i know what i'm gonna do it'd be during
the day i know i'm gonna do it
we'll just do it from there be cool yeah
you'll be able to set up all the camera
for him [ __ ] chin
you're going to be there before all of
them yes after
he already stayed the night there which
makes me question you a lot a long time
ago
it was before all the stuff before i
knew about all the stuff or you know it
could have been
during that time but i just didn't know
about that story i don't know
oh you had no you had no clue about the
hotel until after a cheap hotel yeah
that's literally
it was so it was dirt cheap it was super
cheap i was like
yeah i see you sleep yeah what's up
what's going on in your life we don't
know a lot about you
all right watch my vlogs
how about jimmy's talking everything
seriously or that's what chin said it's
going to be super cheap right now
because of the kovich situation oh so we
getting like but it'll probably be
uh oh two ninety nine i don't know
that's that thing let's just look at one
of these
all right so let's book yeah yeah what's
the reviews on this
forty five dollars twin room with twin
beds and a private bathroom any sweets
no we need more than that do they have a
sweet
i wonder if we can
get the exact richard romero's room
let's see
no they uh they uh closed that off right
yeah they smashed it or whatever
you know so we can't get in there oh
yeah i think they
i don't think they they don't yeah they
just they smashed it didn't kill anybody
in there
oh we got sweet they look dope too oh
look at them trying to make it all cool
what are the reviews on it
i can't even get any rooms what'd you
say oh hold on nine plus rooms all right
now
oh it's it's parties at the cecil hotel
oh my gosh
it's the 14th floor 1401. yeah we need
we need room 1419.
then the real scary room is 1402 so you
want to stay on the 14th floor
you think with a documentary coming out
the prices will shoot up but
i want to see the episode with your that
your homie did on this
uh ghost hunters
um the uh what's your homie's name
zach baggins yeah so i'll have well
we could well either you and i can book
it chen and we'll just have blast for
the 14th floor
all right we'll see if it's there we
have to i'll probably just call them and
book it instead of doing it through this
because we can't pick rooms on this
it's kind of trippy that's hard to find
isn't here nobody want to go there
let's just do this real quick and see
what happens this [ __ ] has a two star
so messed up would it be on a regular uh
wednesday or something like that uh let
me see so
what what what date are we on now what's
today we're uh
today's the eighth so we're at
it would be like hold on 51 52 53 haunt
you and stay down
uh 54 55 56 57 58 59
scroll up march 60 61 62
63 64
65. 66 would be monday the 15th oh
that's if we do three every week which
well we can figure out when i go to
tampa
i'll do this you guys keep uh oh yeah
what i was going to say
what are the reviews i mean i mean it's
right there dude it's [ __ ] haunted
187 google reviews that's three stars
click on some of those reviews
this one yeah that's reason so they
change it to stay on main very spooky
place bill is awesome but it's been a
band so it looks dirty and outside let's
a homeless little guy straight
uh it's closed so you can't go inside uh
that i surely don't know what the [ __ ]
she's talking about yeah
nice place me michael she's surely don't
know what the [ __ ] to see my girl stayed
there some years ago until i found him
we saw ghost hunters coming
out the elevator super interesting
terrible post
pretty cool hotel had a weird dude
follow me through the hotel into the
elevator got to my room and water tasted
a hell of sauce
why would you taste the water with some
cherry flavor
ah that's a fake one i bet it's a week
ago not sure why people were saying this
hotel so bad when i was there had
amazing never seen before black water in
the taps
oh it's all trolling five on five it's
all trolling five out of five stars
i didn't go to like a bad review
five out of five i don't trust it yeah
i need like a two try changing the name
yeah stay on main [ __ ] please
oh so they oh they got oh it's not a
cecil no more no it is there you go
it says cecil but if they renamed it
stay on main stay on man
you ain't feeling nobody yeah i go that
15th jen
excuse me check availability oh yeah
oh yeah february 9th uh tomorrow
oh wow
residency at the season hotel we get a
residency
oh gosh what happened here uh what did
what deal
now yeah all right go to current events
all right
okay so tyron
matthew louisiana uh he tweeted last
night
that his encounter with tom brady
uh there was something that tom brady
said to him that he wouldn't repeat
he then deleted the tweet he was
basically trying to say that
he didn't think it was fair that he got
the penalty but tom brady didn't want
tom brady was the one that chased after
him yeah he then made it seem like he
said something terrible about him and he
took the tweet down
i wonder what he said i don't know but
like my connotation made it feel like it
was something like almost racial because
he said he wouldn't repeat
listen one of the things that makes tom
brady so great is he's very smart
there's not a chance [ __ ] hell tom
brady dropped a racial slur
this is the original and tom brady's
mic'd up he's not stupid
oh yeah he is miked up right yeah he's
not that stupid
here's the thing about tyron matthew
when they played he gave him all
tom brady his respect you know it's
called him like a great competitor
you know and all that now you you know
just how the referees call it the game i
think that
ball he was trying to complain about tom
brady through past interference it was
uncatchable
and he didn't really it wasn't past
interference so i think he was just then
the next play they picked on him
so i think he's just taking his
frustration he's just emotional
yeah but again the referees you got to
blame the officials now i do agree no
even if those penalties weren't there
they wouldn't have won the game no i'm
uh i'm with you
the refs didn't come no the ref didn't
cause it but again chief said show up
the chief
bottom line didn't show i get you but
again the refs didn't help that
it doesn't matter yeah i'll give you
that but again i think those
when tom brady chased him why did he get
a penalty that's all he was basically
the guy but everybody knows the nfl the
guy who the last guy the last guy
and tom brady was the last guy no
matthew's the last guy no because tom
brady chased him
and talked [ __ ] to him that matthew's
like i think gave him a finger no he
pointed his finger to his face then he's
running away yeah
and then he ran away and tom brady
chased him yeah it's tom brady i was
awake for that part
it's tom brady though you know that
guy's got a cool story though yeah tyron
matthews
yeah he was he was telling me about it
uh yesterday
he i mean he's the best defense player
on the field not that night but usually
is
yeah yeah he's just like they didn't
show up but again uh
when he was when he had antonio brown
one-on-one got starts for the touchdown
well that was that was the day after
that i mean that was a play after
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] yeah he wasn't
into it but again him alluding
to like tom brady saying the racial slur
i think it's us
alluding he didn't say racial yeah
that's he sounded like
i had yeah but yeah oh i think that's
because then the climate is wearing
right now but yeah very true
what else you got okay so over
in germany a man was arrested for fraud
and what happened was the prosecutors
try to confiscate
50 million 50 million euro
worth of uh bitcoin which comes out to
be about 60 million for us
jesus and i don't know exactly why they
tried to confiscate this
but they were trying to get his password
to get a hold of his bitcoin and
for a few years while he was locked up
he never said anything
and they were never able to get into his
bitcoin so now
he keeps it uh he's the only one who
can't access it they're saying that he
can't because he's still
in prison what how long is he in there
for uh i don't think it says
he's there for a while though he was
arrested for fraud i don't think he's
there for
a incredibly uh long time
i'm probably hoping he'll probably get
to a point where he can get it
he's going to get out of jail at some
point he's not going to like die in jail
but he bought bitcoin when it was before
i blew up
and that's why it says we asked him but
he wouldn't give it to us
but he they can't take his information
like that or
what are they gonna do i don't know what
the laws are in germany so i don't know
why they would even try to confiscate it
maybe bitcoins like
uh apple where they just at no point
yeah bitcoin that's the nice thing about
bitcoin is that it's super secure
because it's encrypted
that's cool mm-hmm but he has i believe
so he's getting out of jail 1600 bitcoin
1700 bitcoin which is worth 60 million
did he get off and today did you get all
that through fraud
uh we don't know i think he got this
before the fraud but it could be a part
of
his fraud damn i think bitcoin shot up
today it's like 42 or 45 000 now jesus
christ
it's like the highest it's been crazy
probably should be
i know it sounds like i know it sounds
interesting yeah mm-hmm
what else you got cat um and then this
one
is for chappelle and by four chivalry
okay so two more men have been arrested
for
um having relationships with minors
who were a part of the cheered
documentary i know that guy so one guy
was a choreographer
he was in a scene with that girl uh
gabby butler when she was doing a photo
shoot for like a cheer company
yeah uh he was the male model he's a
choreographer and he works with a lot of
kids and a lot of different uh
his name's robert siana yes and then the
other one was a cheerleader who was a
part of the navarro team
yeah he was yeah that dude so there's
two of them going away two of them
that got arrested yeah and they were so
it's three total with jerry included
with jerry those twin boys too they
don't say it's the same boys they just
say
uh kids kids right yeah and because
they're kids they don't really give too
many
oh here it is robert uh was arrested
february 3rd 2021
in virginia and charged with taking
indecent liberties with a child and
using an electronic community a cell
phone
device to solicit the pictures he was
arrested before he was able to meet up
with the child
oh so like i don't know yeah but i
think there was other information on the
phone that lead them to believe that
there was other stuff even before that
with this circumstance when he got
caught it was before he met
just shouldn't cheerleading like i
is it a dark world in cheer yes i mean
yeah yeah it could be a [ __ ] dark
world i mean it that's anything though
anything could be a fight anytime it's
adults with kids yeah
you got to think like remember that the
the [ __ ] uh gymnastics dude
the doctor oh you know what i'm saying
like i said like a
gillian yeah and that dad wanted to
fight him in the courtroom and he said
just give me five minutes yup
first of all i'd be exhausted after that
five minutes but it would look like
still but i guess your daughter
but it's a it's a dark [ __ ] yeah it's
a dark any time
i mean but it's not like it's exhausting
there's there's great things about
cheerleading there's really great things
about it changed my [ __ ] life
but you're gonna get some bad apps but
you're gonna you're gonna get some bad
think about church yeah for the most
part churches are pretty great
but they have access to all these you
know invites some bad apples
yeah like i don't want people to like
knock on cheerleading because it's not
cheerleading less than one percent of
cheerleading yeah you know what i mean
like that's the people that have [ __ ]
you know in this [ __ ] it's just it's
just the wrong [ __ ]
wrong person to be cheerleaders that's
all you know whether you like this not
there's a lot of
gay dudes and cheerleading like no like
really straight man like 80
80
i noticed because a couple of episodes
ago you go 65
he's 99. 99 he was like you know only
one you talk about 90
gay men that they have power over these
you know
little boys like yeah you know see them
same with
same with these [ __ ] uh that's not a
percentage out there
that's the only number we see but it
could be something else oh there should
be a higher percentage of chaosity
what's gay i don't know like a gaydar
one third of male college cheerleaders
had gay sex one third so
only one third yeah damn so if three
people on this table cheer
one is like straight one yeah there was
i mean uh
no one of them it was probably like
i mean how many of us did they ever hit
on you
what do you think i think i don't know
i'm cute as [ __ ]
you're all right i'm all right all right
were they were they like damn chappelle
what's up like
you know i actually didn't get like get
it a lot because
i was i was like the angry dude that
everybody was like terrified of
they knew so they were like this man
this [ __ ] crazy
everyone just thought i was crazy yeah
so like yeah i didn't get like
i mean yeah i never got hit on like that
yeah
i was just [ __ ] i just hated everyone
yeah but i was
but i loved cheerleading weird yeah it
was very weird yeah i hated everyone but
i loved cheerleaders only black guy out
there correct
only black guy no i wasn't only black
dude on my team that's there
i mean especially where you chaired
right yeah yeah
but then kentucky as well right yeah the
south the south is like
for cheerleading but uh texas
uh is probably probably the best state
for cheating
yeah it's like it's like i mean texas is
just like football high football
every everything's fantastic yeah
everything everybody
everything that's true i was good as
[ __ ] y'all
i'm a world champ i believe you oh i'll
bring that ring in i'll show you you got
a ring
they give you rings yeah like big like
big
no yeah big ass rings yeah come on bro
what else you got cat
uh this was sent in by jackie martinez
who's jackie martin i don't know a fan
oh i saw this [ __ ] let's check this out
i don't want to play the music is there
a music let's see i don't even think
there's
nope can't do that so i'll let you see
the video
he's going on top of a bridge with a
bike popping a wheelie
no you're not popping the wheel he's
just riding yeah there's no wheelie on
there dude
so [ __ ] cool it's insane you're not
good you have to be a bike in to do that
you're
yeah it is stressful
oh he's a nice biker where the [ __ ] was
that at
yeah he's really good at biking did it
say where that was at chin
uh france damn
this is mommy who's in uh utah
oh that's right yeah is that what the
kind of the trail was a lot more like
cleaner
i guess this is [ __ ] nuts
they also don't build bridges like that
because this is what people do yeah
whoo one mistake one mistake i know i
wonder if he fell out he fell in the
water i don't think he would die
i don't know how high up he is [ __ ] that
that's beasty like yo yeah
oh it's a different oh it's a different
thing oh
yeah oh no there's like a i forgot what
it's called but it's like those gopros
that are three
three sixty oh gotta get it
yeah holy [ __ ] dude god
damn he did that
then he will already pop the willy at
the end okay that is dope as [ __ ] yeah
it's pretty dope
i don't know if it's worth it but those
dope
all right this one i just saw pop up you
call those people daredevils right when
they do stuff like that
yeah you could are you going
professional bike rider
there's gonna be yellowstone prequel uh
i don't know if i'm into that
really no i saw this doing a commercial
going out
oh i guess talking about his dad his dad
owned the dunton ranch before him and
gave it to him
so it'd be like his grandpa grandpa
mm-hmm
but what did you do why are they doing a
prequel is it being taylor sheridan yeah
where the [ __ ] is my season four
forget prequels where's the season four
doug
you know i'll watch it what am i saying
yeah let me see the teaser chin
hold up it's just just just this yeah it
looks like
oh that they don't
god i love that show that's [ __ ] dope
though
um some mattress dude but 3.4 million on
the buccaneers
anyone wait what happened and there were
dogs you bet 3.4 million
on the three and a half point spread
love it do you use draftkings
promo code tv
yeah and he'd win 2.7 million good for
him man
um i guess this is a new trend oh i love
status oh my god she's so bad
yeah i'm sorry to get that it's okay
yeah so i guess he
she called drake oh no drake called her
and then she said she was too busy for
him and he kind of like what
because this is a new tick-tock trend
you facetime somebody and then you say
you call them and then you say oh sorry
i'm busy can i call you back and the
other person's confused like you called
me
oh there's you and you're just getting
reactions from your friends and famous
people are doing it
he's all what's up girl right here
it's about time i've been waiting for
this
hey i'm really busy can i actually call
you back later
what i'm really busy can i call you
later
that's [ __ ] something i'm really busy
i gotta go
and then she hangs up hey i'm really
busy dead
hey he was waiting on that call bro you
see she's so bad hey chin go to her
goddamn go to station paige
drake definitely is it what is it is it
stassi or style
her name is anastasia she calls herself
us dawson
yeah stassi i think she's better than
she's better than kylie boy this is
kylie's friend she's a gym yeah
jesus christ can you go all the way down
when she's twerking on the airplane uh
on a jet
twerking on a jet same doctor as kylie
huh yeah
all of them do i think all of them go to
the same doctor it's gonna be a minute
that doctor got that
honey now okay you want you want the
kelly jaw all right we'll figure it out
all right hold on is she twerking
goddamn she's bad i know wait wait wait
a minute it's coming it's worth it too
just just bear with me nah mommy
okay okay okay is it the busted
challenge we're we're passing a lot of
bad news no wait brother i'm trying to
tell you this where is that
gosh she got something she's twerking on
the jet you're gonna see everything
she has the only fans no she does have
only she does yeah of course
you gotta i'm sure she makes a killing
is it all right all right well she's
twerking on a jet man okay
and since when was that her best friend
uh they were childhood best friends but
when with kylie it was always like kylie
and jordan and then once jordan left she
hung out with stashmore but they were
all they've known jordan for a minute
just yeah jordan and kylie were friends
as kids
they like grew up together yeah oh [ __ ]
they all grew up together
does jordan come from money jordan uh i
think her
she does like her dad yeah okay i think
her dad was wealthy but then he passed
away
oh wait hold up how old is she before he
goes old enough she's like around my age
25 right
okay
she in the black by the way hold up [ __ ]
here we go all right here we go
which one is she she's in the black now
listen you don't see a lot of them
sophia
i'm not gonna tell you you know which
one private jet
i felt like i was on this trip okay
hold on here we go here we go hello oh
that one that's just a tease don't worry
about it
oh she pulled the pants down everybody
hello about to see
okay get these two white girls out of
here she's trying to show her she's
trying to show her
oh there you go there it is yeah zoom
out
you see it jiggling yep mind of his own
yeah right
we got more her mom's on the plane
here we go oh it's more brother
god damn who's the white lady in the hat
brandon okay it's more it's coming
what are they doing they're turning up
on the gym
what the [ __ ] she has some ugly ass
friends
your friends
that one was kylie's assistant oh good
for her
mm-hmm i think kylie's on here on this
trip as well
i don't see it where are you going uh
it's so sophie richie uh
birthday who's sophie richie uh lionel
richie's uh daughter
and she's oh scott scott yeah really
yeah no she has some she changed her
outfit and she gonna throw it back at
you and pull her pants down
how many times have you watched this
malik huh don't worry about that
hold on give it to me where is that give
it to me really true
that's our mom's yeah jesus that's
correct okay
all right that was a terrible video yeah
for that hyped us up i apologize what
else you got
um i think that's pretty much it this
one i just thought was interesting i
didn't know he aged this much
oh mark mark cuban yeah i'm sorry is
mark cuban the butler for the adams
family
[Laughter]
oh my god he's talking about bad angles
no he's just he's looks like he aged
overnight named lurch
bring up lurch bring up lurch for me it
is a spot on reference
i'm talking about the old school black
and white adams family lurch
and you come out images
there this guy oh gosh solid riff
yep there's mark cuban
go down to the one in the blue yeah that
one yeah right something yeah
damn that's all the reference yeah
what's is it a video just though that's
just an interview i just i just saw him
and i was like whoa
he looks so like really aged overnight
creeping up on you
are you all caught up with the uh i'm
busy with the ugly stick
i'm busy challenging i've never heard of
it until oh just right now i'm too old
but that was funny watching drake get
off [ __ ] height
you know he's hitting that because he's
always uh yeah so i'm busy late what the
[ __ ] you talking about
is on world star there's a compilation
she did to every single one and i'm like
[ __ ] you called me
yeah like so many were like wait what
they called me
the nba uh inside uh tnt they did the
same thing uh
kenny the jet smith he called like uh
who do you call uh
all the big names bro you called me you
called me i'm gonna do it for y'all
what yeah i know i'm gonna do yeah we'll
get my phone
uh-huh call next time y'all call
everybody
is that it that's it all right man i'm
in florida february 26
27th bring that tom brady energy tampa
florida
tickets at f a t k z dot com
sun and then the next state is miami
florida bunch of florida
miami florida march 25th through the
27th miami improv
get tickets now at f a t k z anything
thick
thick boy related go to thickboy.com
that's thick with three c's
if it ain't three c's that ain't [ __ ]
thick boy specialized collab
once those are out they're out we're not
restocking those because it's a limited
edition with uh specialized so we're
running low on inventory
so get your long sleeve thick boy uh
collab
uh long sleeves short sleeves water
bottles
thick boy smiley thick boy short sleeve
thick boy tie-dye
get it thickboy.com chappelletown what
we're about to beat
kansas city daddy kansas city man
february 25th through the 27th i'll be
at the comedy club of kansas
yo what's up with the barbecue cause
they say they got the barbecue out there
here's the thing all right so they're
gonna tell you that it's not as good as
texas it's just not
they don't you had it there it's true
they gave you that look through i've
been headlining through
hot second true all i do is eat barbecue
i'll never eat it before a show ever
again
because it makes everyone sleepy and
heavy oh yeah we were ahead we're not
doing that
we're never doing that again we're gonna
buy it and then save it for after the
show because they've wrapped it was
sleepy and [ __ ] yeah i felt like [ __ ]
um they they're more of like a dry rub
no they don't like it saucy they know
they need sauce
i like my [ __ ] sloppy sauce yeah yeah
well i'm i'm bringing white mike with me
so drop the right
drop the [ __ ] uh recommendations
anyway you can't see that i know you
guys are gonna hate on me
whatever but uh the barbecue is good out
there but texas has the best barbecue
texas you're gonna listen like people
shout out kansas city
kansas city kansas city they're up there
it goes texas kansas city
they're up there texas kansas city i'm a
great barbecue in st
louis barbecue nashville lewis
and then denver oh dimmer's got good
what wait till we go out there we go to
brothers barbecue two british brothers
went to all the spots
and culture vultured their [ __ ]
recipes and made it all into one
victim fantastic what's great the
following weekend i'll be in austin
as well march 5th through the 6th at the
vulcan
uh gas company only and that's limited
capacity
[ __ ] tickets only two shows one show
each night
get those [ __ ] tickets uh also i'll
eat you i'll eat your [ __ ] barbecue i
don't know how are you doing [ __ ] i
ain't doing [ __ ] that first week in
march
would you oh you're trying to go kick it
i have to come through come through
that's what greg was about to sing
are you in the gym what's happening
kids go see chappelle in kansas city and
austin come see me in tampa in
z miami com we out you know what i'm
saying
for z anyways let me walk up in here and
introduce myself i'm chappelle
mr cool lacey hey be quiet over there
yeah wuhan hit us man shout out to the
chinese new year man
yeah that's what i'm talking about man
we get them all around bruh
shout out to brendan shaw for cutting
them up for me
yeah he cut him up for me and i had to
play with his kid dog that was like that
was like an exchange
i know right here
it was so
you guys you can catch me in these
streets
doing street stuff you catch me these
streets rolly boy
um shout out to the homies at suplex man
mikey almost drowned with the
you know whipped cream i saw the little
videos hit me with the dunks
yeah yeah i had to change the laces too
chin you see me
yeah two different times well there's
two different shoes okay
oh okay okay uh-oh and back almost gave
up back almost gave up now
he know what he goes to stanford
come through with it don't hurt them
russell fight too